even when you can't see my dogs they're
always here they're always just one foot
off camera but this is my journal entry
for September that I'm getting to you in
November and I'm not going to keep you
too long in this intro because you
certainly waited long enough but hang it
up
what happened September Bob iger's book
came out thunderstorm happened that
scared the living piss out of gypsy poor
Jeb's so here's the month of September
thank you again for your patience and
let us transition into the journal with
a puppy it's trying to punch the guy
okay punch the camera that's not
punching it Groundhog Day is on Netflix
it's a classic it looks great because
it's in 4k how funny it is
it's just timeless holy [ __ ] that's
Michael Shannon
Michael [ __ ] in Groundhog Day he's like
18 so last night I put my video up of
the Dave Chappelle comedy special and
man there were people in the comment
section I pissed some people off bad and
they're correcting me big time they're
like Jeremy what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you it Chris had wings that melted it is
burn I'm sorry I meant melted where
there's a will there's a way and where
there's a way there's a Star Wars
Galaxies server
I just watched Star Wars which I would
call a new hope but I was gonna say the
original Star Wars because it was the
harmie despecialized edition it's so
good the movie is so timeless they're
just looking at me like oh he's being
nice they didn't you jumped up on my lap
now oh now he's done they're just being
crazy oak spells and propel P oh don't
look at my face no right there such a
needy little dock
[Music]
so I'm watching a YouTube video called
what's the deepest hole we can possibly
dig cuz I'm watching it just because and
that question is being raised just
because it ever happens we will have
done it because just the spirit of human
nature
what's the deepest hole we can dig in
the earth I don't know let's just put a
lot of tech there and find out for
ourselves this was a little dust
floating around here point is this is
what I do with my down time I'm just I'm
on a youtube rabbit hole now I should be
doing that it chapter two spoiler talked
video it I mean there's no real rush to
do it I'll do it tonight people are
still watching the video I guess there's
a rush for the YouTube algorithm but
like I've ever smart I'd have it up
today like this morning but tonight I'll
be up tomorrow morning he'll be fine so
there is that no I'm thinking right now
and yes leaning up against this wall is
my favorite place to to vomit my
thoughts I'm thinking about human beings
you know the human interaction human
experience social dynamics etc let's
think about this things a lot I think
about fish in a pond I told you this yet
I don't know if I haven't I'm about to
know so I see it as fish in a pond right
all right you take any city any town any
pocket of civilization anywhere these
little groups of civilizations whether
they be these cities are towns and
they're really their pawns these little
pawns full of fish fish of course are
people and the fish in these ponds think
that they're pond represents the ocean
but it doesn't just represents their
pond but because their perception of
reality is dictated by their pond of
course they're gonna think the ocean is
like their pond it's just another pond
it's not really the ocean as a whole
because there isn't
Oshin as a whole there's just a group of
pawns it's just how I see it that's just
how I see people and their interactions
and there's basically what social media
has brought us to a world where people
could just kind of be in their little
they could be fish in these little ponds
and that's that well social media has
brought all the pawns together and now
all the pawns are fighting over who gets
to posture as the ocean and the
entertainment industry Hollywood which I
grew up with Hollywood being like the
weirdest [ __ ] group of people ever
and what now they're posturing is
reality because they're the loudest fish
in the loudest pond that's weird
so however you want to see it that
particular reality that particular pond
it's not really reality as a whole for
most people I love a good thunderstorm
all right so we are peeing hardcore I
got a lantern so I look like a Tom berry
from Final Fantasy 7 or pug from 6 and
so gypsy hates the Thunder so I built
this really flimsy fort now she just
stays under here actually it's not for
her it's for me it's a blanket for gypsy
this is how we did it back in the day so
you get these little treats they get
them high and then they stop caring
about these though I mean they don't
stop caring Who am I kidding you're
still anxious
look like a strobe light outside oh okay
I see a big bright look there we go I
love thunderstorms I love lightning
storms I always have there's something
you've got to turn off the lights just
watch it from the window I would set go
outside but I feel like some people
would take that to an irresponsible
level so I'm not gonna say that never a
few years ago my best friend was my
roommate and it was a great lightning
storm great thunderstorm I was a good
one and it was the best one in like ten
years and we chased this thing to a
graveyard overlooking Puget Sound we
chase this thing for a while until it
just kind of dissipated but uh that's a
great memory man I would be a storm
chaser for sure all right first
thunderstorms now frogs I'm pretty sure
about something biblical is happening
does anyone else do the spin jump on
these things like it's it's it's
necessary right let me try to do it [ __ ]
I can't do it with one hand there we go
[ __ ] hang gliding in this game it sucks
this is attempt number five thousand
four hundred and seventy eight didn't
stick the landing
whatever epic game moment right here
this is one of the best end credit songs
in the super nintendo generation i am
dragging ass today and i don't know why
but screening of ad astra though so
bring on the coffee like unusually tired
my friend migraine so some excedrin some
coffee which helps migraines I'm feeling
a bit better now I should totally edit
that at Journal that'll be on the agenda
today at the western Washington State
Fair that Western Washingtonian still
called the Puyallup fair I mean friends
day of just fair it's not the fair
without scones it's the best 25 bucks
ever spent at the fair actually I was
like 15th she's not dead
it's good there's actually probably the
best food to prepare yeah and we have
and a lifetime supply of overpriced
biscuits and jam and that's Morgan and
Adam right over there
all my fresh make weird faces on this
thing
Oh felon we have to rescue the bread
pretty sure those things are those
little things in the tank of your toilet
affair
I mean it's called enterprise but it has
healing and predator on it I mean that's
just crossing lore right there I mean
I'd like to see the crossover in real
life but I mean come on my bingo fingers
itching
this really is the shittiest level in
the entire game okay so I did something
kind of simultaneously awesome and
terrible at the same time first of all
let's think about how awesome Marty
McFly and the DeLorean looks and Metal
Gear Rex back their bosses all of them
but I bought the Batman set on the 4k
you know it's my god my dogs are
freaking over there hold on I'm trying
to bring Church to the people but I got
the 4k said it's all steel books they
look how sexy in there but in my mind I
was like hey they're on sale which means
I'm paying full price for the Burton
Batman's I'm getting Batman Forever and
Batman and Robin for a free if not
discounted cuz I can't justify paying
full price for them it turns out the one
that was 60 bucks
there was the Nolan's set this one was
full price which means I paid full price
for Batman Forever which I could have
fun with and Batman and Robin but I'm
sure the color contrast is gonna look
sweet on that because the colors are
gonna pop right I paid full price I
posted an Instagram picture of the 4k
steelbook Batman set and now just bring
on the Arnold puns you guys have fun
is actually if I could peg my earliest
theatrical epic moment you know that
movie that I saw in theaters roles like
uma ghoulish movies Burton's Batman my
uncle took me when I was a kid and I'll
never forget it and to pay him back over
ten years later I got him into
Battlefield Earth when I worked at the
theater I'm sorry man
best I can figure this scene is the
reason mimes freak me out so I set off
to film a sponsorship segment because I
have to film the sponsorship segment and
get it to the sponsor tonight and so
they can have a day to approve it so I
can get my review of Rambo up on time
easy and then I'm looking for my SD
cards for my camera and I'm like where
is it I found it on the floor it may or
may not have been chewed up so the
question becomes which one of you chewed
up my SD card who was it
obviously you're still interested in I'm
not giving it to you oh my god where's
the other one there's one for the audio
device where is it off to Walmart or
something
thank you only things open right now so
I hope they have the SD cards I need all
right so the best ones they had not as
good as the ones that the little
monsters ate or at least one of the
monsters but yeah I had two SD cards
[ __ ] if I know where the other one is no
eating the new SD cards you're both cute
I film on the table too which means one
of them jumps on the chair and then up
here my SD cards were right there oh man
I'm just glad I didn't have to email
them and say sorry my dogs ate my
homework
that'll been a little embarrassing you
enjoying a day in the life the glamorous
life of a youtuber no I'm playing my
switch right now I'm playing Super Mario
Kart super nintendo version and I
realized
that there are kids out there who will
never know that Princess Peach was once
named Princess Toadstool it's like that
they'll never know that I've run into
people I color toadstool and they're
like um her name's peach like there's
some people who don't know a reality
when Princess Peach wasn't even named
peach she was Princess Toadstool
Street Fighter 3 is my favorite Street
Fighter game the last hand-drawn Street
Fighter game the character animations
look good it's just I love Street
Fighter 3 do so where all that stuff was
used to be blu-ray 4k discs and they've
condensed their blu-ray selection to
this little kiosk oh what a bummer I
used to love coming in here and just
looking at movies it's the end of an era
friends alright I found them they're
actually to the right of the entrance
next to the TV's still it's just like
two kiosks two rows well I guess four
rows two sides each sound like it was
what are Y indulge in first also casinos
great just got the email invite for the
Joker screening I see the Joker on
October 1st which is still before you
see this so I guess it's pointless to
record this but I wanted to record it a
bunked Joker's grinning it was funny
he's more Killer Croc than penguin dude
Batman Returns as a gothic tragedy like
everyone's life sucks and in the end
it's sad you know penguins funeral sad
it's awesome
that's such [ __ ] you're not mom ooh
you're not ma'am ooh your wart don't try
to lie I just realized
two of Tom Cruise's wives are in Batman
movies also don't ask me why I'm
watching this I got the set I might as
well watch the set wait a minute dr.
chase meridian seduces her patient i
just realized that bruce wayne has this
thing that he does right he goes out at
night he's Batman he fights crime he
blows off steam it's like it's what he
needs to do and then this kid comes
along is like oh no you're looking at
your new partner whenever you go out at
night I'm gonna be right behind you it's
like dude you're intruding on my time
like Robins a dick how you gonna stop me
what a little stalker this is what
happens when you stalk people you just
you kill their their joy of their hobby
all right
Sega Genesis mini God it's been a couple
days actually a few days of him playing
Selda funny thing as this is the genesis
mini controller and this is actually my
old-school Genesis controller they
always feel a little different even the
Super Nintendo is on the the SNES Mini
like the plastics smoother on this one
than this one this has the red buttons
which I feel like the generation 1
Genesis had this is from the generation
2 Genesis but they never feel quite
identical high-definition graphics in
this time it's actually true there we go
father/son day in nerd world well this
actually has a solid library beyond
oasis phantasy star 4 earthworm jim
contra hardcore Castlevania bloodlines
all right let's see if I still remember
the Super Sonic code and the debug
[Music]
all right so you hear that coin ring and
you go back to the title and you hold a
and push start and you can go into level
select so that was for the level select
1965 917 in the sound test hold I push
start go here so the code is one nine
nine two one one two four
so you hear that coin I forget if that's
the debug or supersonic and then there's
four one two six it's for twenty six
right hold on there we go now you go to
whatever level you want hold a push
start the sonic has superpowers he could
turn into coins and TVs and all sorts of
stuff you can turn into anything you
want and you can lay him down like that
push see look like that a little thing
there
it's the debug mode but for our purposes
we're just gonna load tails up with 50
coins
there we go jump supersonic I don't know
it's one of those codes I'll never
forget I'll just I'll know that code
until I die killer does break the game
singing don't like about the sonic games
is that they don't have flow they don't
have the flow they should look there's
always obstacles that block you when
you're getting momentum sweet levels
over any that's supersonic in debug mode
end level select Thank You toys-r-us for
providing the corpse that spirit
Halloween store will possess once every
year so I guess there's a book that came
out that shows that basically Star Wars
under Disney Disney went against what
George Lucas wanted and George Lucas is
disappointed in Disney Star Wars poor
Lucas it's like we all gave him [ __ ] and
then they burned his baby in front of
him just funny because I talk so much
[ __ ] about Lucas and you know the
prequels there now I just feel sorry for
him compacted you know it's at least the
prequels had that Star Wars vision can
always say that about them you know they
still felt like the vision of a guy like
one person's vision one man's vision
that was getting to the end and he knew
where it was gonna end when he started
it there's no of course feels about as
organized as a monkey trying to [ __ ] a
football at this point like what's it
going I don't even think they know point
is it if the father of Star Wars doesn't
like it that's something that's not
nothing last night I ordered zona the
Andrews second runner for ps4 is like
$15 it's a good one like if you haven't
played the zone of the enders it's like
this great game that apparently was
deemed not worthy of a third game
because the framerate issues
for the ps3 remaster and they wanted to
see how sales for that when people found
out there are framerate issues they just
didn't get it it was a whole thing that
I still have her for ps2 Oh
worth getting again for ps4 empty
promises it's been 10 so a couple days
ago I uploaded a video with my thoughts
on the George Lucas Bob Iger book
segments you know it's a George Lucas
felt betrayed a lot of support for that
video I really appreciate it you know it
was uh when I was going to bed the night
before I was supposed to see abominable
I'm supposed to see that Bumble movie
and I was like no the George Lucas said
cuz I just heard I just read little
passages and just heard about the the
Bob Iger book and what he's said in
there about George Lucas feeling
betrayed and I was like now that's the
video tomorrow
I guess I'm not seeing bumble anyhow
thank you thanks for the support I guess
that's the thing that's a that's the
thing about reviewing movies online is
that your mindset like a person's
mindset will change and the perspective
will change as they grow I mean that's
what growth is right growth a change in
mindset is a byproduct of growth if your
mindset never changes if your opinion
never changes if your perspective never
changes you're not growing and that's
not a good thing but when you when you
put your opinion out there on the
Internet
it's out there edged in some form of
digital stone and so when your opinion
does change on something then you you're
met with a little more resistance which
overwhelmingly I didn't get I did not
get with that video I did that's why I'm
just so appreciative of it you know
because I've seen a lot of people have a
change of heart
online or on YouTube videos and they
were not met with such support which is
why I [ __ ] love you guys also check
this [ __ ] out I've been very
contemplative about one movie in
particular which is Batman Returns the
last couple nights I haven't made a
journal entry and I don't know why cuz
the people need to know
this so Batman Returns is a complete
gothic tragedy and everyone's life in
there sucks but Oswald Cobblepot he's
kind of written like the hero heinous as
his motivations are in killing children
as heroes in a movie like that they're
going along and then they have that dip
their lowest low you know at some point
they're like oh my god I'm not gonna get
through this and then they could they
rise and they come out on top right like
whether it's Rachel Dawes getting blown
up in Batman Returns you know that Lois
Lowe where it's just it all feels the
night is darkest just before the dawn
right the person who has that in Batman
Returns is Oswald Cobblepot he's going
along then loses all of his credibility
at that speech because Batman recorded
the things that he said and then people
start throwing eggs and tomatoes on him
and he just starts shooting his umbrella
gun and he runs and that's the character
that has that low where they lose
everything and then they're like you
know what I'm gonna rise come out on top
only as motivation was to blow up a
bunch of people and kill a bunch of
people and got them but still he said
he's still won in that movie that has
that arc that heroes usually have I
don't know what to do with that
information I think it might make the
movie a bit cooler so there it is that's
my month of September as it started a
couple months ago and ended a little
over one month ago but I'll get you
October actually pretty soon
comparatively speaking I just kind of
want to edit a little bit each day until
I get it to you and then hopefully in
the next week or so so you won't have to
wait so long for that one so thank you
very much for the support you give these
videos and my videos in general my
channel in general I appreciate it so
all right I'm gonna let you go and once
again we will do the outro with a puppy
dude intern Duden Duden
[Music]